seriously guys this is the best James
Bond movie ever made for about the first
hour Spectre now normally when I do
movie reviews I try and keep them
spoiler free at this point though I'm a
little bit late to getting to see the
movie I figure most people who were
really gung-ho to see it have already
seen it by now plus the stuff that I
want to spend the most time talking
about is all spoiler stuff so that's
going out the window and before I get
into what I'm gonna be spending the most
time on which is where the movie falls
apart I really want to point out that
what I said in the intro was not a joke
and it wasn't hyperbole I love the first
hour of this movie just starting from
that extended tracking shot I mean it's
gorgeously shot the action is inventive
in his hard-hitting it's fun it's
intense I love that pretty much all the
actors prac oh they found somebody's a
barrel roll a helicopter I love that the
starting premise is basically bond doing
a mission that he doesn't even know why
he's doing it but he's doing it as a
post mortem mission for em but he trusts
her judgment so much that if she says it
has to be not it has to be done and he's
just gonna deal with the consequences I
love the stuff with monica bellucci cuz
it's like it's your standard bond sex
little divergence but it doesn't slow
down the pacing and you still feel the
tension going on and I love him getting
to rome i love that meeting that happens
ya ain't before that I love him with Q I
love him with em I love the he buddies
in that meeting I love the car chase
that follows I love when he tracks down
mr. white I love the heck out of pretty
much every single second of that first
hour and then the character of Madeleine
Swann shows up and things start going
downhill now I do want to be clear on
this it's not the fault of this
character the characters fine it's about
standard she plays it just fine it's
just her appearing happens to coincide
with the point at which things start to
come apart at the seams of it if i were
to paint sort of an overall reason as to
why this is the point that the movie
started going downhill it's that the
feel of the thing just started shifting
now I knew going in that sort of the
intention of this film and the vibe of
it was
bringing back elements of classic bond
that the day of Craig era hasn't really
done so much and I thought we were
getting that extremely well in that
first our little moments like when the
building is collapsing and he just lands
on a couch that's just there it's not so
goofy as to be unbelievable but it's
just a light and fun moment it's nice
he's banter with Q and Q going you know
you did couldn't bring it back in one
piece and all of that stuff that's again
that's very old-school that's very fun
and what it felt like in that first hour
cuz there's other stuff like that too
but it feels like they found a story to
tell like good this is our story and
then within that story found moments and
opportunities to insert classic bond
tropes but what it feels like once we
get Madeleine Swann on board is it stops
feeling like they had a story that they
could fit bond tropes into and it starts
to feel like they just had a list of
bond tropes that they're just checking
off as they go along well let's see Bond
girl introduced kidnapped and rescued
within a half hour of the audience
meeting her check villain base in the
middle of nowhere check bond strapped
down to a table and tortured check a
literal ticking clock check and we're
just connecting the docks from one bond
trope to another and I know that there
are people out there because I've seen
this reaction already going look these
are classic bond things why are you
questioning them this is just what bond
is but the problem is you just spent the
last three movies showing us that this
is not what bond is anymore now I'm not
saying you can't reintroduce these kinds
of aspects but because you have spent
the last three movies basically
distancing yourself and being more
realistic and grounded about it if
you're gonna introduce these new
elements you have to justify them you
can't just throw them in because that's
just what bond does the way that you
could in the classic era because back
then that is just what bond was but
that's not the case now and even when I
think back to the bond era it was
usually at least a lip service to
explain why these things were in there
even though the real answer was because
it's a bond trope like Blofeld's base in
the middle of nowhere in that crater I I
don't know why it's there
I mean it's not a lab where he's dealing
with some materials that he has to keep
away from society there's nothing about
that location that has something like
right there geographically that he has
to be set up there as far as what's he's
doing it's basically it's a surveillance
farm pretty much I mean they think I set
that up in an abandoned parking
structure there's just no reason given
it's just here's the villains base in
the middle of nowhere but like I said
classic are they at least gave us a
reason like it may be stupid but I know
why Drax has a space station and
Moonraker I know why Alec Trevelyan has
buried a satellite dish underneath a
lake in gold and I same thing with the
torture scene for bond he strapped to a
chair and tortured why I honestly I
don't know aside from it's a trope they
wanted to reinsert because Blofeld's not
trying to get information from it he's
making Madeleine Swann watch but he's
not trying to get her to crack either he
doesn't even seem to be enjoying it so
it's not like he's torturing him for fun
he's just kind of doing it which of
course does bring us to blow fell which
is kind of the big thing here and in
most ways he's the big thing that
doesn't work because first of all we
have to talk about the fact that it's
it's like a twist or revealed that this
is even Blofeld in the first place which
was just really stupid I honestly did
not believe this guy was gonna turn out
to be Blofeld not because I didn't see
the indicators that we all saw but
because they were saying this is not
Blofeld and I actually thought they
can't be so stupid as to try and pull
that trick off because what's the
immediate comparison you think of you
think of the reveal of Khan in Star Trek
into darkness now just to be clear me
personally I didn't have the big problem
with the Khan revealed that I know a lot
of people did although I understand why
people were upset by that I kind of
rolled with it but it becomes that sort
of fool me once shame on me fool me
twice shame on you things so the fact
that this movie only a few years after
star trek into darkness do it and
arguably that movie didn't even get away
with it that well you're gonna do it
again that just shows contempt for the
audience cuz yeah we were all going come
on Christoph vols he's blow fell doesn't
he and they were like no
he's not Blofeld no no no no no
definitely not blow fell but come on you
brought back Specter if you're bringing
back Specter why wouldn't you bring back
both he can just admit to us that he's
booked no he's not Blofeld no no no and
then you get to the movies like and he's
Blofeld ha we got you know you didn't
get us you lied to us and we didn't even
believe you it's like that gag from
Family Guy where Chris goes up to Megan
goes hey Meg guess what I'm thinking
it's not kidding I don't know Chris what
are you thinking it was Kitty hahahaha
that's what it feels like the movie is
doing and frankly it's insulting and the
fact that we are in a rebooted
continuity him revealing himself to be
Blofeld has no meaning we just have him
show up and be Blofeld that's not a
twist unless you are a fan of old bond
and all the fans of old bond already
called that so if they just had a
blood-filled for the from the get-go
that would have helped it wouldn't have
fixed the whole problem though because
we got the second part of why Blofeld
doesn't work which is this revealed that
he's James Bond's brother kinda sorta
foster brother stepbrother whatever how
is that relevant how does that give us
anything because we're shown nothing
about their relationship about their
history about their past we have no idea
what their life together was like I mean
there's a tiny bit of a hint from
Blofeld that he resented bond for coming
into his life but we don't know if that
was evident to bomb when they were kids
were they friends when they were kids we
didn't did they were they at least
cordial just bond feel betrayed by the
fact that this guy was kind of his
brother he doesn't seem to feel betrayed
actually he doesn't seem surprised at
all so what about their relationship
with our younger makes him not surprised
by this I don't know the answer any of
that because the movie doesn't show us
the only thing that I can think of as to
why they might have done this might have
been to try and offset the fact that the
stakes overall are a bit weak because
spectres big plant is just basically to
consolidate the world's major
surveillance and then take control of
that now while I'll grant that is a bad
thing I understand why that's something
we don't want to have happen that's
pretty low stakes in James Bond's world
you know no one's going to die as an
immediate result of this nothing's
blowing up there's no death laser it's
just they can watch everything okay
that's bad I guess so I feel like they
tried to pull off what goldeneye pulled
off because golden i also had lower
stakes cuz then that one Trevelyan was
going to electronically steal money and
then basically use EMP to shut down all
the electronics in London which again a
bad thing that probably would have been
a couple of immediate that's from that
but ultimately it's just a blackout and
London could have recovered from that
but the way they offset the low stakes
was by raising the personal stakes
because the history between Trevelyan
and bond but in that movie they showed
us that history and they showed us the
sense of betrayal that bond had towards
him and they don't show us that here so
if that was what they were trying to do
by introducing this history they botched
it completely and if that's not what
they were trying to do then what were
they trying to do I would have bought
the motivation so much better for
Blofeld if he just said look I had these
plans going on and over the course of
the last three movies you kept stumbling
into and screwing up my plan so I'm
pissed at you and I'm gonna torture you
now I want to roll with that that was
that would have been fine but this this
whole notion that they've got history
and they grew up together with why what
does that what purpose does that serve
look I want to be clear again the first
hour of this thing is phenomenal and
honestly in the second half it's not all
bad either there are some good points
the fight on the train is terrific we've
got some good moments like that but the
thing is the film as a whole it started
good it got great and then it hit that
point where it started to dip down and
then the good stuff that's in the latter
have it just sort of evens out for a
minute before continuing to dive
downwards I was frustrated when I left
the theater and as I have thought about
it since then it's just made me angry
and I just have a hard time believing
that the first half of this film which
is so brilliant and perfectly executed
in these classic bond elements
wonderfully integrated and the second
half of this film where it's just a
going through a check
list of tropes were made by the same
people this is probably the Bond film I
am most frustrated with it disappointed
by it's not the worst Bond film it's not
even the worst Daniel Craig Bond film
that's easily still quantum of solace
but it is definitely the biggest
disappointment I've ever had watching
bond so that's it for me have you seen
Specter if you have what did you think
about it whatever you thought drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned